hello I'm going to uh open the
subcommittee work session on Senate Bill
149 related relative to a nurse agency
and um
I know how many people are here for that
or the next one but um
but we'll proceed I know Jackie said you
had some thoughts
thank you Mr chair I'm torn between
um
putting too much
too many mandates in the bill
and I'm more interested in getting
something started
so my thoughts were that
um there's one one there's a page two
which I can't find my bill right now has
um online
eight to nine I thought if we struck out
for such a reason
which regarded the commitment of nursing
agencies making
um commitments to two places at once
just eliminating for such a reason would
give that class more strength those are
the those are the comments that I had on
that actually I agree because reading it
it isn't really
um it isn't listing any reasons in in
that section nurse agencies shall not
commit the services anyway it goes on
and there aren't any reasons listed and
then it says for such a reason which I
think basically doesn't make any sense
um
I mean two the not recruiting employees
on the premises I don't know how and how
useful or enforceable that'll be but
I'm not seeing it as causing harm
um
you know nursing agencies not may not
facilitate the placement of any licensed
professional to license the suspended I
mean that's actually not legal
but I understand uh these nurses are are
not necessarily licensed in New
Hampshire so it might be tricky to
figure that out
um
and when I have the other one I have
concern about is Nurse agencies may not
charge a higher uh a health care
facility a higher amount based on the
presence of a communicable virus unless
there's an emergency
um
I mean the one hand maybe that's a
normal part of the job on the other hand
depending on what it is I mean I might
not be widespread enough to have
generated a state of emergency but
the agency might actually have to pay
more to hire people to show up and if
they do they should be able to pass that
on so
I do have something of a concern about
that any other anybody else in the
committee have uh thoughts on any of
this
week
but that I mean that yeah that happened
with covert I mean that would be up to
presumably the contract between the
nursing agency and the nurse but that
could increase their costs so that's the
sort of thing I was thinking about
anyone else have thoughts on anything in
the bill
I will just look at um
as we look at these bills the effective
date is 60 days upon passage and I look
to the director
about is it better to put where
none of this takes effect if you look on
page one line 18 uh
16 beginning January 1st 2024 should we
put this actual take effect at that date
as well or is it 60 days is that to get
you up and running and get rules and all
that in place director Courtney if you
want to come out
thanks for the question Lindsey Courtney
executive director oplc I think making
it effective 60 days
um is appropriate because it would allow
us to enact rules and then subsequently
require people to meet that standard
thank you
anyone else
okay actually if you could uh stay up
there
thanks
um
so I mean do you have any
thoughts on the issue I raised about
being able to charge a higher amount
based on a communicable disease
because I know in covid
um
actually I got a bunch of sisters in the
health facility Healthcare business and
in covet although that was a state of
emergency something might have similar
issues that wasn't widespread to have
had an emergency declared
they were paying people a lot of money
to
to work somewhere else and part of the
deal was they'd have to put you up in a
hotel for 10 days or whatever afterwards
in quarantine before you went home I
mean that's a significant expense they'd
have to recoup somehow and I could see
that happen in other circumstances or
who knows what so I don't know what your
thoughts are on
I just think generally it's pretty
difficult to legislate
um and I'm not taking a position on this
bill but I think it's pretty difficult
to legislate
um
reimbursement or costs of salaries
essentially because the market
consistently fluctuates
um
so I'm not sure that legislation would
be the best route for that but we we
don't take a position okay
um
the other question I have is on the
nursing agencies may not facilitate the
placement of a licensed professional
with a license that's suspended
I mean as a practical matter how would
the office do you think become aware of
it and then and what could they do then
so typically when a license is suspended
every nursing facility is or is is
typically required to
um check the status of of a particular
license as part of their accreditation
so some facilities do that on a regular
basis some facilities contract that out
and they get notices that an individual
has been suspended but typically as part
of the credentialing and hiring process
one would um
check the status of a license and uh
that's our so that's already happening
um I'm wondering if this is different
because they're high they're having the
agency place them they don't even know
who it's going to be maybe until they
show up and the license is likely not a
New Hampshire license so how would that
work so to work here you'd have to be
licensed in New Hampshire whether it be
under a compact or a temporary license I
read this to say that the nursing
agencies themselves have to validate the
license prior to placement okay so they
would have to have some kind of New
Hampshire license for this yes yes
whether it be temporary or compact or
otherwise authorized practice okay great
thank you
anyone else have any questions for
director Courtney
so Jackie are you all all sad or you
have any anything else on this
anyone else
um is there anyone else here for this
bill
yes please come up
I mean she I saw her first I'll
and um
if you can uh give me your name good
morning my name is Lynette Han Shoemaker
uh if you can spell that
h-a-n-d-s-c-h-u-m-a-k-e-r
and Lynette is a lie l-i-n-e-t-t-e
okay thank you and that's the spelling
lesson for the day
well people have come to this country
from all over the place with various
spellings I people have trouble with
mine I want to get it right so
well good morning and I thank you for
allowing me a few moments of your time
I am the president and CEO of Evergreen
Place in Manchester New Hampshire we are
a smaller non-profit assisted living
community that provides services to 52
elderly residents here in New Hampshire
I'm writing in I'm here in support of
the bill Senate Bill 149 in the hope
that we can apply some reasonable
standards to staffing agencies
I employ
approximately 32 full-time equivalent
employees many of whom are part-time
and since the pandemic like many other
Healthcare communities we've been
understaffed
in order to meet our requirements under
our regulations
we use staffing agencies to fill
vacancies as well as last minute call
outs
um
in addition to the exorbitant cost we've
had to absorb
we do have concerns about staffing
agency practices
for my organization
we absorbed about 79
000 in additional expense due to Hiring
Agency to either fill vacant
openings or last minute call outs so I
can tell you that this is extremely
damaging to our bottom line especially
in respect to the fact that I hold 20
Medicaid
beds in my community which
basically states that even if an
individual coming into my community can
pay eight hundred dollars a month
with the stipend that I'm given through
the choices for Independence
um
of 56.88 a day I am falling very short
of being able to
um
meet
the growth
in my community
this
um
the expense of having agencies work in
our community
threatens our financial viability
especially since we have not reached
full occupancy since the pandemic
to give you a better idea
staffing agencies can oftentimes cost us
three to four times the cost of what is
a normal wage for our nurses and aides
okay yeah I think sorry for interrupting
but yeah we're
it's not a public hearing we're our
interests in comments but I have one
question then for you about this
um I mean I could see this bill if it
went through my
reduce the amount of kind of last minute
uncertainty around what the cost will be
um
but there's nothing here that I see
that's going to actually reduce your
cost there's nothing I mean if you if
you can't find nurses some other way
you're presumably going to have to get
them through an agency and they can
charge whatever they can get
so I don't see that in a major way this
is going to help your bottom line is
there something I'm missing there well
it isn't going to help my bottom line
you're absolutely right however being
able to have some reasonable standards
in place which is what this bill is
laying out for us as a whole would go a
long way toward helping our
organizations in particular
items that are not part of contracts
that we sign when doing business with
agencies such as the 20 to 40 dollar per
hour covid surcharge that is being put
upon agent organizations other assisted
living communities that have outbreaks
is one way to
um to help us financially all right
thank you
we also please representative
so what is it that prevents you from
putting
um limitations in your contracts with
the agencies for example
to say that we won't you know that we
will pay up to blank an hour for nursing
or why why is there something that you
can do within your
um
contract
that would
make the payment of nursing nurses more
predictable
or more you know allow you for a better
budgeting I'm sure that's
that's a viable question and it's a
possibility I think what we're aiming
for here is sort of a standard or a
number of standards that we can put
forth that will affect all of us at the
same level
oh
so I know that in Hillsboro what they've
done is they've I believe this is in
Hillsboro
counties it's one of the nursing homes
County nursing homes they've put a limit
like say that we will not take traveling
nurses that are within a 50 mile radius
of our facility which prevents
uh nurses that live nearby from
hopping from one place to the other and
bidding out their services do you see
that perhaps as an effective tool you
know traveling distance so that people
who
um it limits who's available and who's
you know
uh that might be one way of of
addressing this I don't know
I don't work for a nursing home I don't
work with travel nurse agencies what I'm
talking about has more to do with local
nurse temporary nurse staffing agencies
where nurses will come in and I might
block book them for a number of days
over a month but they're not necessarily
these are not people that are traveling
across the state or coming from
longer distances someone else may be
able to speak to that
okay
anything else
yep
um representative Bailey
you had mentioned a 20 to 40 dollar an
hour I presume uh covid surcharge did
they explain that to you in any way or
justify it or no and I think the the
bone of contention for us is simply that
if these items are not listed in our
contract then why should we have to pay
them they're showing up on our invoices
um and they're not necessarily part of
the contract
language when we initiate a contract
with an agency so it seems a little
backhanded if you will
um that you know that charge along with
a last minute fee when you know things
happen and you have a call out and the
last minute you're looking for an agency
person to come and do the nursing duties
because it's a requirement in order for
us to maintain our license
um charging us for those
types of things can be a little bit
daunting
it's taken aback because it's not part
of the language in the contract
and if they rewrote all their contracts
to include that
have having experienced these epidemic
or pandemic or whatever if they then
just rewrote all the contracts that
you know if there was such a thing we
will be charging this then it would be
in your contract correct
thank you right and actually as uh
representative groda said it sounds like
I mean I don't know if it's valid for
them to be charging something that
wasn't in the agreement
um if nothing else when you did the
contract you could do something like
you're not going to pay anything that's
not explicitly in the contract which
hopefully would take care of that I mean
my they might choose if you want to do
that not to take
not to bid on it I suppose but um
but if you could get someone to do it it
would sound like that's the sort of
thing
that um
you know almost might be more effective
than this or at least or in addition
and you know because
surprise charges that aren't in the
agreement don't seem right and if you
say you're not going to pay them up
front then it could protect you from
things Beyond just what's covered in
this bill so it's just a thought so
there was someone else who wanted to
speak thank you somebody else want to
speak on this Mr chairman if I may just
briefly I mean I'm not sure
foreign
this bill is looking to solve a sort of
a problem but this committee is not
going to be able to solve a breach of
contract or something that's not written
at a contract right I understand I'm
just I'm I guess what I'm trying to
figure out is um
there seems to be a perception that this
will solve problems that it doesn't
appear it will so if I may fall I I
think it will help because we heard
specifically of examples if you look on
page two starting at line five this was
an area that was specifically mentioned
time and again that these
companies were
moving nurses around from place to place
based on a higher bid qualification and
I think that will solve that alone will
solve a problem with the numerous
agencies said was happening right it
will certainly help
um
yeah that's
questionably because we we heard that
they were having to hold over staff and
paying you know time and a half or
paying whatever they had to and forcing
folks to work beyond the hours they
should because someone wasn't coming in
to fill a position
no I understand okay
um just
want to see if there's anything new that
might be useful that this gentleman has
thank you Mr chairman I'm not sure if
it's new or useful but I'm Brandon
Williams I'm the president CEO of the
New Hampshire Healthcare Association we
represent assisted living facilities
nursing homes Cedar Crest Center for
children with disabilities we've already
testified and supported this legislation
I won't make any uh policy arguments in
favor of it to avoid redundancy however
just in response to this hearing and
some of the questions asked
I think with respect to the up charge
for the presence of a communicable virus
within the facilities I know in talking
with the owner of a New Hampshire
staffing agency that was something that
he never charged I didn't think it would
be right to charge even during the real
depths of the covid-19 pandemic because
that's why uh personal protective
equipment exists and that is something
that the facilities themselves provide
to the contract staff that come into the
facility
um
because we don't have transparency as to
the rates as does Massachusetts which
actually caps the rates or as to the
elements of the rates is a number of
other states require Connecticut Iowa
Missouri being a few examples we don't
really know exactly what the elements of
the rates are so there could be some
consideration for the fact that there's
an ongoing pandemic I think what really
calls providers is just that there be a
discrete up charge for the presence
again of a communicable virus and so I
think this prohibition is reasonable
um
as to the question of whether you can
make the contracts more predictable we
did discuss this at the hearing on the
bill that these are really contracts of
adhesion arguably but at a minimum I
don't think anyone could disagree that
their boilerplate contracts uh when you
get these National staffing agencies for
example career staff which is
headquartered in Dallas Texas they're
not tailoring these kind these contracts
are not up for negotiation in terms of
the elements of the contracts these
contracts are works of art when it comes
to the legal work that has gone into
them and so a facility that's looking to
uh fill a shift tomorrow evening
it doesn't have the ability to negotiate
the elements of that contract so
um I think otherwise the only comment
that I would make is I know and director
Courtney could speak to this uh that the
statutory reference should probably be
changed here to an open statute and
again I would leave it to director
Courtney to say what that is although I
think RSA 326 M was O as opposed
most of the references that we see
within the bill to RSA 326 B uh I think
it would be a better place to in the
open statute and uh with that I'd
certainly take any questions but I
really appreciate your time on this
beautiful day can you give me your name
again please my name is Brendan Williams
and I'm the president of the New
Hampshire Healthcare Association okay
thank you any questions
okay thank you thank you Mr chair
director Courtney if you're still here
if you want to see what she went out all
right well
um
all right
anything else
you know what I just do want to make it
clear to everyone that this is due with
nursing agencies right and if you don't
work with nursing agencies this this
bill that doesn't apply to you
um I just want to make that perfectly
clear and
um I am okay with recommending to the
committee that we if we we wanted to
discuss I think that the
the changes that
um the elimination of four
uh these reasons are and then also I
think we need to assess out a little bit
that clause about the up charge because
to me it's not clear
it's not well defined what that means so
we might most want to strike that from
the
um the bill because
you know the flu is a communicable
disease and so to me if a facility has
the flu
there shouldn't be an up charge for that
doesn't make sense to me
so if we can't define it
I don't think it should be in the
legislation right I agree I mean the
only uh reason I would
mean if we do those two things I would
be fine with it my only
quash at this point is the comment about
where it is in statute and we might want
to check with director Courtney to see
if although was she involved in
recommending this
let me check my notes on that but um we
have the attorney from ah oplc here that
may be able to
yep thank you
good morning Douglas selster how oplc
general counsel I'm not going to be much
help here that was executive director
Corey's comment uh I wasn't consulted
about that I think if it clarifies
the language and it makes more sense to
put it in the open statue
when you said it's her comment so did
she say something about moving I don't
recall that I don't either that was the
testimony I just heard I would have to
confirm with her before
okay I say anything no there were no
comments from oplc in the committee no
no she didn't mention
something about there was I'm so sorry
there was something I have a note about
RSA 326.
and that this should go into it should
not go into RSA 326 is that the RSA
that's referred to in the bill
um
B right instead of two line five
actually a number of places 326. right
so I have this and that was the comment
that director Courtney made
um I had this little tiny so I would
think that we need to just make sure
that
um
we addressed that with her before we
write an amendment
so unless there's anything else
um I'll just close this and we'll have
to get in touch with her I don't know if
she's going to be here for the latter
part of this but she is coming for the
second half so we'll be able to talk
with her yes
good morning I'm David Ross I'm the
administrator of Hillsborough County
nursing home I just wanted to speak to
um I believe I heard you recommend that
you would like to strike uh Article 4
which
um excuse me the article related to a
communicable diseases
um what the article currently says is
that they may not charge an up charge
for a communicable disease unless there
is a declaration of state of emergency
and I would urge you to support that so
it wouldn't apply in the case of flu or
other communicable diseases it would
only apply that they would be able to
charge an up charge in the event that it
was a pandemic level that warranted a
declaration of state of emergency well I
think I mean
it sounds like it would apply if it was
the flu and there's not a state of
emergency because they may not charge in
that case so
it sort of seems the other way around at
least in my reading depends how you look
at it but but this appla this prohibits
something
unless unless right unless okay yeah it
prohibits the up charge unless there's a
declaration all right thank you thank
you
I mean I'll think about that but so we
we need to hear from director Courtney
anyway so does anybody else have
anything else on this
I'm gonna it's not a public hearing so
um
yeah well I mean if you got a quick
point
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
subcommittee my name is Bruce Berkey I'm
with she Infinity Capital group and I
represent uh Interim HealthCare nurse
staffing agency here in New Hampshire
and the American Staffing Association
and with respect to
charges up charges that are outside of
the contracts there is a remedy
available today
and that is the Attorney General's
office the consumer protection act under
RSA 358a
is a resource for any business in the
state of New Hampshire and certainly if
there are violations of a contract
between two parties that is a place
where it can be addressed
and with that I'd be happy to address
any questions all right thank you thank
you
actually
no I don't have a question I think the
comment that he makes is valid and I'm
wondering whether or not that's
something that we can refer to in
statute
right that we can tie this to the
Attorney General's office statutes on
contract that those things apply
I don't have any problem with that I
it's sort of well I know that it's sort
of like it already exists but I think
that it's okay yeah I would I would
discuss that maybe do you have a comment
on that attorney Astra hubbed Hound I
did just run next door and ask Lindsay
and she said she does agree with the
move to 326m
I just wanted to share that she wants to
she wants it in 326. I believe so m m
okay okay thank you so
um
I mean there's references to various
parts of 326 B
or is this all it's all new
um so this would you just want to move
it to wherever the the end of 326m
correct that's what she wants all right
thank you
anything else I'm ready to close things
out
okay I'm closing the uh subcommittee
work session on Senate Bill 149 and
we're going to start up again at 11
o'clock thank you
thank you
foreign
so I'm going to open the this discussion
I'm merging to mental health boards and
social worker Compact and I want to
explain how this works and set
expectations this is not a public
hearing
um my intent is that this is going to be
mostly if not entirely a discussion
between members of the committee and and
director Courtney if we have questions
we think there's somebody here can
answer
will ask if eventually what comes out of
this you know in the future is some kind
of legislation I mean that would then
have a public hearing so that's to make
clear what we're doing here today
um so director Courtney if you could
come on up
and um
what I was uh
planning on doing is
um
I mean if you could talk about what what
the goal was what the plans were on the
part of the original hb2
dealing with mental health practice I
think in the original bill it starts on
page 160
and goes on until
um
I think the end of the
181 and anybody I mean you know we're
not going to be real formal here if
anybody on the committee has a question
as we go through just speak up it's fine
thank you Representative members of the
committee executive director Lindsey
Courtney oplc um so I think I can speak
to further Governor obviously but I
think the whole purpose of what was
proposed in House Bill 2 is really to
reduce uh bureaucracy
um reduce uh the number of boards reduce
the number of board members we have
currently about 350 within the office
most boards have a structure that are
around seven members each with two
public members public member positions
are extremely difficult to fill so you
could see throughout hb2 that I think
the goal was to reduce moose boards to
five with one public member with respect
to the mental health boards what was
proposed in House Bill 2 was really just
to merge the number of boards to go from
27 members I think down to seven is what
was originally how many
um separate boards exist today in the
mental health practice area well so
there are five boards that regulate to
some extent
mental health providers that being Board
of Medicine Board of Nursing
Board of Licensing for Alcohol and Other
Drug use counselors on the board of
mental health practice and the board of
psychology
so what House Bill 2 proposed is to
merge the latter three which psychology
laidac and mental health practice
but within those boards there are
separate
there are separate so how many of these
if you look at the last the last three
boards that you talked about how many
members are there on that board on those
boards
oh geez I don't know that off the top of
my head representative there's 27
members across the three of them
um
I know that there are folks here who
could better answer that question off
the top of your head I'd have to look at
the statute which I'm more than happy to
do
but really that number is irrelevant if
we're only talking about three you know
you see what I mean right
and then
um
and I'm wondering
there are things that there are boards
that are functioning better than others
so I do want to have that conversation
these are the things that I think we
should
um talk about is exactly how many
members are in total of the board on the
board that we're talking about merging
or that gets reduced to
and how we
and then and then also
um the functionality of these boards
because
if they have strong representation
they are experts in those fields am I
concerned with merging boards that have
these kinds of specialties
is that we get to the lowest common
denominator where we lose that
that uniqueness and understanding of
that field and since mental health is
such an important field right now
I don't want to complicate it or or
nullify its meanings when you're looking
at special practices
certainly so just to take the board of
psychology for example their their board
is currently comprised of five licensed
psychologists one licensed School
psychologists and three public members
um we currently have one public member
seat filled again historically the
public member seats are very difficult
to fill the requirement to have a
licensed school psychologist dates back
to March 2020 we just recently filled
that one and then the other five
psychologist seats are presently filled
and they function they meet every month
um
so certainly they're they're not having
the Quorum issues that we've seen with
respect to other boards I think the same
is true for the laidac board as well as
the board of mental health practice
we're not seeing Quorum issues I will
say with respect to the board of mental
health practice
we do run into issues because they have
very specific requirements as to
um the composition of the board in
particular they have to have one
licensed pastoral psychotherapist that
one is presently filled it has been
filled for a while but I think there are
only 11 licensed pastoral
psychotherapists in the state one
licensed clinical social worker that's
filled one licensed School social worker
that one historically has been somewhat
difficult to fill
I think mainly because they're working
in education environments a licensed
marriage and family therapist a licensed
clinical mental health counselor and
then the next two are historically
pretty difficult to fill one has to be a
member from a Community Mental Health
Center and one has to be a member from a
community health center
and those had those were recent
additions I think day back to 2020 as
well those are historically are very
difficult to fill and then they also
have a three public member requirement
and again public members are very
difficult to fill so how do sorry how do
public how are public members
um how do you work and how do you
advertise to those and who appoints
those and how do they get placed on
board so most of them are gnca governor
and Council appointments
um a lot of it is done by Word of Mouth
historically we had placed ads in the
bar news seeking attorneys
um but because we typically Market
because most of our positions are filled
by less licensed professionals we send
out Mass messages to licensees but they
can't serve the public member position
and I think that's part of the problem
we haven't figured out how to connect to
a market of individuals who may be
interested in serving and oftentimes
public members have a particular
interest in a field and so they may seek
out a membership on a board based on
their subject matter interest and
they're really we just have we just have
not been able to figure that out and be
successful follow-up so what is the
benefit of having a public member on the
board
I mean if it were up to me I think one
of the the state could consider if it
would work which it wouldn't
um for the reasons I just mentioned but
public member provides uh the public
input if the whole purpose is to protect
the public
obviously you need input from the public
it also if to the extent that you have
more public members on a board
um than uh licensed professionals it
provides that protection that immunity
that we've talked about under North
Carolina Dental because the board or the
profession is not regulated by a
majority of active Market participants
so some states actually have public
member majorities
and that has been something that has
been presented as an option for
regulation and various audits but I
don't practically think that would be
successful here because we can't even
fill the seats that we have
um one thing I know as you said there's
other uh states where they you know they
may have a majority of public members do
you have any idea how they're recruiting
public members I don't but I do think
that's an Avenue that we should look at
yeah
uh yes thank you Mr chair Miss Courtney
um if
have you reached out to groups like Nami
uh there are there are a lot of support
groups for families of
patients of clients that I know would be
interested I know would I know you would
get responses so I'm wondering if that's
yeah and I'm sure that's just one of
many family
support organizations in the state
yeah so we we do work regularly with
associations to get out the word
um with respect to there are a lot of
statutory prohibitions on having
involvement with associations and being
considered a public member as well that
one has to consider for example
unrelated here Pharmacy
um you know you can't have any interest
in the practice or the provision of
Pharmacy whatsoever or some statutes
prohibit you from being married to
somebody with that interest so it
significantly Narrows the pool but yeah
we do work with associations follow-up
follow up
thank you
well my my recommendation of them was
not that you would have like a Nami
worker but that they know how to contact
the public members I I guarantee you
there are many many many many many many
many many many many
of us who would love to have a voice and
certainly broken system and have never
been
aware that there were even opportunities
like this so I think that those
organizations know how to reach out to
the general public that does not present
a conflict of interest certainly
right
um so you mentioned the three that hb2
is looking to combine it please remind
me what are the other two you said there
were five yeah so the others are Board
of Medicine they regulate psychiatrists
and then Board of Nursing aprns or
advanced practice
um
registered nurses
I I have a question I have a suggestion
yes so I'm thinking that what we might
do is look at these three boards
look at the compositions of them
make them more functional
and see where that takes us because
if for example
um I looked at the psychologist board
and they record they regulate three
different practices
and if to me
it seems heavy-handed to have three
public members on a board
um I don't know you know there's five
psychologists one school psychologist
so I don't know if we could or is is it
possible here's the other
idea is it possible that these
um members are
chosen by someone other than appointed
by someone other than the executive
Council
is there some way that because to me
that seems like a huge hurdle right you
have to the governor they have to find
somebody they have to appoint them they
have to vote them in blah blah blah it
takes away I think the role that the
public member is supposed to have
because a lot you know it could be that
these people have and I'm just looking
into this I'm just this is something I
thought of
um because of all the to-do lists of the
executive Council I don't think that
this is at the top right they're going
to be a appointing other things like
judges or
Commissioners or something so is there
another vehicle other than not that I
want to step on the governor's toes
you know God knows we don't want to do
that but we don't want to um also impede
public perception I mean if I wanted to
be involved and bored I'm thinking of
myself
and the answer was okay well you have to
be appointed by the governor that is
like to to most people is going to be a
huge hurdle
if I could comment on that
um
you know I
I think in general
these kind of things the governor would
welcome I mean if there's some other
organization that can they don't have to
appoint but they can they can make
recommendations anybody can make
recommendations and I I think basically
my experience with the executive Council
does when a vets these things just to
see if there's some problem with the
person where they be I mean they're not
it's not their job to go out and find
people and the governor has somebody at
least one person I think
in his office who tries to find people
for these things and I'm sure they would
welcome
help so I don't having having this check
where the governor and Council approves
I don't have a problem with that but
they don't have to do the full job of
finding people I don't think sorry do
you know that the director of
appointments is here and I'm happy to
offer insight into what the current
process looks like if you would like
um
we have an online application somebody
submits their interest they apply online
they submit their resume and they need
two letters of reference and then we
make sure if it's a professional person
that they have a valid license and they
fit the description of whatever the
statutory requirements are and then we
send it over my understanding is there
are not a bunch of people that are just
waiting to be appointed
um from a public member seat the other
thing that you may want to consider is
that there are some statutes not the
mental health
that allow organizations to appoint or
nominate people that can actually get
problematic from my perspective because
the purpose is to protect the public and
oftentimes you have associations and
their job is to promote the profession
which is very different
and so you don't necessarily want people
being seated who wear to hats to promote
the profession and to protect the public
because it's very difficult to separate
the two so that just some things to
consider I can understand that but it
seems to me that there's an easier way
of doing this and I think that
no offense to applying online but that's
very impersonal when it comes to
something like this okay you know you
you want somebody who is
uh
I I just you know I just think that this
is something if we're having if we're
having a difficulty in filling the
position there's some there's a reason
and I'd like to know what that reason is
and
um so
I think that's an important that's an
important thing well one again one
comment I make is I'd suggest if I'll
get to you I'm on my side
um
you know if there's a number of other
states are doing this with more success
I think before we try and design
something
and change the process if you could look
into or have somebody look into how that
works elsewhere how they find people
and and vet them and whether there's
lessons we could take from that that
might help us
um yeah and uh representative Schmidt
thank you Mr chairman so I don't think
that the problem is that it's a
complicated process I think that the at
least partially the problem is that
people just don't want to serve in these
positions in many cases and in other
cases as representative Gould was
alluding to earlier they have no idea
that there's such an option even out
there so duh there's all kinds of things
where people say really the world is
round but it looks so flat I mean Texas
the roads go on and on bro it's so
flattered are you sure the world is
around yep we're sure okay so the bottom
line is there's a lot of ignorance out
there it's not that it's hard to get
something through the process if you've
got the person
I'm against tinkering with the process
until we look at and your suggestion I
think is a very good one to look at
other states but we we have
I think both most of the public members
come from the boards themselves that
suggest practitioners
uh you know look to friends relatives
debtors whatever uh they suggest their
own public members in many cases all
right yeah if I could comment on that I
mean that's actually not what we want we
want people that are
members of the public and not as closely
associated I think with
with people in the process even if they
technically meet the statutory
requirements and I mean I I had no idea
there were public members in these
boards until I got involved in the State
Rep business and on Edna and I I know
plenty of people
I mean I've talked to a lot of people in
town I know people in town who retired
with a range of interests and expertise
and I'm sure
there are some of them who would be good
and willing to serve if they had a clue
that any of this was out there so I'm
curious how other states manage to
publicize this stuff
um and you know New Hampshire is
different in some ways but maybe we can
learn something we used to have
something in this country called Civics
that were taught in school but we
stopped teaching it so people don't know
oh really
we have an executive branch or we have a
Judiciary representative moffett's had
some bills to try to attempt to fix that
how successful they'll be I don't know
we'll have to see and um
we're happy to work to to look into
research what other states are doing and
to do what we can to further promote the
public member
um
that
role I think
um obviously we're challenged by
resources as well I mean we could we
could run ad campaigns that's not
something that we presently have the
capability of doing but there are a
whole host of things that we could do if
we if if that were
um
so I'm asked one of the reasons I'm
reacting to this because I'm thinking is
that you're within your responsibility
is that not the boy's responsibility to
fill the board as opposed to you I don't
think it's either I don't think it's
either responsibility to be honest with
you I think that that's something we
could do because we are providing
administrative support and we need a
fully functioning board in order to
um to to meet our objectives
you know the governor has to nominate
but it's not even the Governor's job to
go and search for candidates I think
um I think the way the statute is
structures it presumes that there are
people interested and are just aware of
this and it doesn't necessarily require
any one body to nobody's responsibility
so it doesn't happen
well you know we do take an active role
within our resources I think that the
problem is
um you know we have a lot of other
things going on and we don't have the
resources to meet members of the public
I think if you really want to advertise
this year would be doing advertising
campaigns with WMUR you'd have PR
campaigns you'd be re-reaching all sorts
of ads I mean I mean where else are you
going to reach the members of the public
it's certainly not through the Avenues
the traditional avenues that we have
which is through our licensees our 242
000 licenses and I agree with you
representative lake is that we don't
want to just have friends and friends
and friends so how do you reach the
public as a whole right
um actually represent Bailey had a
question for us and then representative
well I hope mine are kind of simple I'm
relatively new to this I've had some
time but are these people paid yeah they
receive a per diem but it's it's minimal
yeah
yeah what's the function I mean it's a
board of experts I keep hearing yes and
then suddenly we're gonna have a
non-expert yes
um
they're there to watch the Watchers or
what are they there for no so they're
they're there to represent the Public's
interest and I'll give you an example
um
you know if they're um
we have had situations where a board has
reviewed a complaint and they're
reviewing it from the expertise from the
from their perspective as an expert
um but it's very important to have the
perspective of the public member when
they're reviewing the complaint if their
goal is to protect the public because
maybe
it's not misconduct whatever is alleged
in the complaint but maybe it should be
because the Public's perception and
expectation is that that be considered
not standard of care for example and so
um I think it's important that the
public member be able to engage with the
members of the regulator the other
members of the regulatory body to make
those decisions proactively
follow-up are you seeking people that
have some expertise in these or at least
some interest in these medical fields or
well that's we just went out on the
street and picked up 10 people or
something they wouldn't know anything
about psychology I assume I mean
honestly the the best people who are the
people who don't know anything about
what it is that you're intended to do
because they represent the public and
most members of the public don't know
anything about the practice of
psychology
but they maybe could say hey wait a
minute that doesn't sound right yeah
correct that's what we're about to do
right yeah
thank you representative gold thank you
I love what you were saying in terms of
the advertising piece and I'll just give
this one short example I was in DC for a
conference and Maryland Public Radio did
these announcements that I was like why
does New Hampshire not do this like
other states do public information
campaigns and this was one was about
zipping in traffic like when you're
entering a highway to zip every other
car like what a novel freaking idea so
I've taught everybody I know how to zip
since I heard that on a public
announcement on the radio and so I think
that if we can figure out who does those
in other states because it shouldn't be
your responsibility and the worst thing
is to have the board make the decisions
about who the public members are not
because I mean a good functioning board
will recruit good people but when you
get a rogue board then you're you're
locking out any any good people so I
really like that where you're going with
that and I think maybe we can help with
finding out who could who in New
Hampshire Government Can can do those
kind of PR campaigns for things like
this yeah we just created a position of
a public information officer designed to
facilitate better Communications and so
we're starting to build out a better
communication strategy which I think
this will necessarily be part of that
um you know I think it would be helpful
you know if the legislature feels that
this is an important objective for us to
prioritize we can certainly do that
obviously there are resources uh funding
Appropriations associated with that you
know if that's the direction we need to
go right now we've just been working
within our existing resources and our
Appropriations and it's not really
working so and
I mean New Hampshire does do some of
that I think Department of Safety
Department transportation does some
level of PR campaigns plus they've got
their electronic signs out all over the
place
um but I don't think the state does a
lot of that I have a
couple of questions so you mentioned the
three boards that hp2 proposed merging
have there been problems with them not
being able to do their job due to lack
of quorum to if so to what extent has
the lack of public members been
contributing to that you know what how's
it going yeah they do not have Quorum
issues none of none of these boards have
Quorum issues I think that and again I
can't speak for the governor but I think
the purpose was to help promote
collaboration as opposed to silos and
one of the bills that you heard this
year was to expand the scope of practice
of an M ladak some concerns that we
heard and oplc didn't take a position
but some concerns that we heard from the
board of mental health practice is that
they would have the same scope of
practice but not be regulated by the
board of mental health practice and so I
think that one of the justifications
toward merging these boards was
certainly not punitive but it was to
Foster collaboration between disciplines
that may have
similar overlapping scopes
okay so I mean I have a question I was
just gonna say I mean maybe in the
future we could look at some level I
mean maybe merging the laidac and mental
health practice boards might make sense
you know I don't know somebody disagrees
but uh representative groda I want to go
back a little bit to that appointment
thing and there is is there someone from
the governor's office that can answer
the product it can go through the
process because that would be I think I
would be interested to knowing that if
there's somebody who's who can do that
she's here you can do that is it okay
with you if we sure yeah come on up
no tell us how this works
for the record Deanna Juris and the
governor's director of appointments
um so you're looking at the the one
person who puts everybody on these
boards uh through the governor and
Council process
um
so I'll just kind of talk you through a
little bit about what that looks like
um the function I won't speak for the
council I don't represent them obviously
I work for the governor but I am the
governor's liaison between his office
and the executive Council
um so I spend a fair bit of time with
them I've learned the process better
than I ever thought I would
um
I would say being nominated and
confirmed through the council is the
easiest part of that business meeting if
you've ever attended a governor and
council meeting with those contracts and
um you are more intimately familiar than
Manny just how much
State resources how many state resources
go into just preparing a contract to get
on that agenda it is extensive it is a
weeks and months long process often
multiple departments are involved in not
just the not just the office that that
brings the contract I would say it's
much easier to be nominated and
confirmed on a on the governor's list of
nominations than to have a contract to
prove it to the state level I don't
director Courtney would you agree
yes
um so all of that to say
um
we all know New Hampshire is a unique
place right the executive council is a
unique executive body and the purpose of
it is to slow down the process to have
very very public accountability on state
spending and on these appointments so a
number of these almost all of the
licensing boards I would say there are
very few exceptions are just out of the
governor's office but the large majority
of these licensing boards go through the
council because of the public
accountability if the governor is the
sole appointing authority the
recommendation comes into our office and
the letter comes out and they're on
right and with the council process much
like in other states with the Senate
confirmation
um
the the letter comes into our office the
governor still is the sole nominating
Authority largely
um for licensing boards for sure
um but then it goes to the council their
resume is made public their contact
information is made public they're
expected to reach out to all five
members
um so that we're not just it's not just
friends of you know whoever is in the
corner office right so that that
promotes that process I think that's the
purpose of it is it cumbersome yes it
absolutely is and and I think that's by
Design
so in terms of the process really though
the online application it seems
impersonal but it really streamed lined
and I think it improved the experience
for people who are applying
um what happened was sometimes we would
get a letter of interest but without a
resume and no letters of recommendation
or you know we would get three of the
four pieces and administratively between
my office and staff between oplesc staff
trying to support and then the licensee
you could be emailing back and forth for
weeks and weeks just to get a complete
application together and then as we know
right the council only meets so often so
those the appointments are only reviewed
so regularly so we actually have
streamlined it and very much shortened
the process because you once you hit
submit right you can't hit submit until
everything's in and so once you've
applied you've done it there's there's
potentially Outreach between our office
sometimes we have multiple candidates
applying for a seat I would say
anecdotally that is
um less common I don't have people
beating down the door of my email inbox
to serve on these boards um
so we we process every application
individually and they all I mean they're
all read by by members of staff and
reviewed there so I mean I'd be happy to
answer any other questions about that
process
um actually I'll make one comment I've
gone through this because
um I'm a Justice of the Peace which goes
basically through the same process and
I forget if I did it online or there was
a form I said I think it was a form and
I sent it in with
you know two other JPS who
you know couldn't recommend it or
whatever me and the process it just
cranked through and it it happened and
it was
you know that that wasn't the issue it
sounds like the issue is finding public
members and you know what if anything do
you do to try and find public members
for the boards we do rely heavily on on
stakeholders from a number of different
areas
um even I was just thinking through
um
a full disclosure I served as a state
representative in in 2019 and 2020 and I
would say there's no one that knows your
community and better than than all of
you right there's 400 representatives in
these communities and it is a great
resource of of doing that Civics
education that was one of my favorite
things was just explaining here here's
what's happening in state government
people don't even know about some of
these processes
um and it was really I had some amazing
conversations just out and about with my
community talking to voters talking to
people about what was going on and so I
I was thinking about that would be a
great resource for me for people that
you have interested I do have state reps
that reach out this is a constituent
who's interested in this you know
whether they're a licensee or a public
member and I think that would be a great
resource that also would be free right
I'm not paying for advertising
um I don't have to put signs out for
that right but um you're interacting
with people day to day I would say the
same thing is true for those of us in
our office as you know we're interacting
with lots of people
we have lobbyists who are very well
connected as well that support us in
that way but as you know New Hampshire
is a very frugal State the budget is
lean that is no exception in the
governor's office so there's no padded
advertising budget whatsoever so it is
largely word of mouth and Outreach in
that regard so director Courtney is
there
director Courtney is there
um
maybe one convenient place on the
website where people can see what are
the opportunities especially for public
members on boards yes certainly so if
you go to our home page and I'd be happy
to send this to you I'd be happy to send
it to the entire general court if they
would not be confused as to why I'm
sending that
um but if you go to our home page drop
down how to be interested in becoming a
board member you click on it and it'll
explain the process it all it also
explains the commitment because we want
people to understand we want people to
be active and engaged on these boards
because as as you know that's another
issue on certain boards so it explains
the commitment and what's involved and
it just provides the online application
right there and we get it automatically
through our emails multiple people we've
edit in terms of making sure it's
complete and then we send it over to the
governor's office so I have a request if
you write up something brief that
describes what public members are and
what they do and then a link after that
I would be glad to sponsor that as a
member notice in the house calendar
wonderful I'd be happy to to do that
thank you and as far as I you know I
wouldn't recommend mailing it to the
whole house without at least talking
with the speaker but
valid
if I might just add really quickly that
licensing boards are one very small part
of the council confirms thousands and
thousands uh over ten thousand roles and
board members and that that's just that
go through the council
um not including things that just come
from the governor's office or as you
know other legislative committees so
there are a lot of pointees in this
state and and really there's 1.4 million
people so at some point you know we get
to our percentage of volunteerism
although lower than it used to be is
still pretty high just by the nature of
these boards but sometimes we have
people serving on three four even more
boards
um in that way which is obviously very
kind
um but it does get challenging but just
just to keep that in mind I would say as
as you're considering changes to the
process or or not that licensing boards
is it's not a small piece of this
committee but it is a small piece of the
councils even just their appointing
authority role so I would just be
mindful of that they're doing this for
across the state government I understand
I mean for the notice thing I was
thinking public members to do what you
had suggested was to have the Reps do
Outreach to let people in the district
know and maybe recommend people who
would they think would be good and not
just licensing boards there are a lot of
volunteer boards I think we could we
could potentially make it even more
broad than that
um yeah there's one Consolidated place
people could go look at all that and
maybe you know making this too
complicated will cause problems so I
don't want to say you know make this
big and complicated I will tend not to
read it yeah
uh representative Schmidt
having served on this committee for for
17 years now I can tell you the subject
has come up on many occasions and also
being on the uh joint committee on
uh legislative
administrative rules uh
even getting people to come to conquer
to testify
if we find somebody who's a volunteer
who's interested in serving we try to
get him to run for State Rep because
there ain't enough people running for
State Rep in many cases so it and I've
heard it constantly people talk about
um we're we can't get enough people to
serve in the local communities on the
Town Council or city council or you name
it the public is not sufficiently
involved because this is heavily
volunteerism in this state so there's a
lot of opportunities and they're not a
lot of people that's just a reality yeah
so far there's in my district there have
been at least three constituents who
called me about an issue and uh let's
doomed them I've talked them into
running and they've gotten elected so
it's dangerous calling me
yeah uh representative Gould
thank you Mr chair and thank you guys
for your testimony and taking my
question so
um I think that what you just talked
about in terms of the sheer volume and
and The Limited population I
um
I was going to say I think New Hampshire
people you know New Hampshire citizens
really love to volunteer but then I've
learned since I've come into this role
that New Hampshire isn't what I always
knew it to be and we have a lot of
newcomers so I can't speak for for that
population but
um and in our district I know that a lot
of people want to volunteer but it makes
all the more sense in terms of merging
boards if we can limit the number and
and get each board functioning really
really well and in regard to the topic
we have in front of us the Mental Health
crisis that we have in New Hampshire
they I love what director Courtney
mentioned in terms of getting out of the
silos and getting some collaboration
going because if we can't get laidac and
clinical social workers and
psychologists to be willing to sit at
the same table and address these
problems and help solve them then the
the population the police department in
my community that that 80 percent of
their calls are for mental health and
domestic violence what hope do they have
if you all can't sit together and come
up with Solutions in in a collaborative
manner that are going to solve things so
I I really support merging of the board
and I haven't seen or heard anything
that tells me why that would be really
horrible other than power and control
and I think that that is the worst okay
I'd like to make a comment on that
because the mental health board's
responsibility is although they're
involved with the
process of mental health in New
Hampshire and they're responsible for it
the boards themselves serve a different
function
and I think it's very important that we
do that and merging the boards I think
is detrimental to solving the problem
mental health and so I don't think that
we should make any decisions today based
on that there's a discussion this is a
discussion and I really think that we
need to understand the issue of mental
health and that is quite different than
how oplc and the boards work together
that is a completely different thing and
I think those need to be separated
because they are distinctive
um they they are distinctive in in their
own right
right I I mean no um
one thing is I know there are people
here want to speak and we're not going
to do that but that doesn't mean you
can't contact the committee or contact
people in the committee and provide uh
whatever information you want we're not
I mean this is to be just you know for
us to get information
um there's no bill before us
so there's there's not any solid
decision that we intend to make today
um it's to get some ideas and you know
anybody uh from the public and provide
you know
email in input as well
or arrange to talk with somebody
separately also follow up Mr chair yep
follow up I'd like to thank
my esteemed colleague from from the
Seacoast for that uh reminder that we're
just here to gather information and I
also wanted to point out we did get a
letter from the board of psychologists
and email that talked about that their
um Community three community members
were fully staffed so maybe that's
something new
but at any rate I was happy to get that
information and I think the gathering
information is an important role and
thank you for the reminder
anything else for anybody on the
committee otherwise all right I'm going
to close this uh discussion but it's not
the end of the discussion I mean
there'll be ongoing stuff and people can
provide input and uh
see where we go
and
foreign
hi everybody it's one o'clock and we're
going to start
um so today
is not this is a subcommittee workshop
and what we're working on is what was in
house built two
and um
involving disciplinary actions so you
might remember that in-house Bill 2 and
House Bill 655 there were Clauses that
removed the disciplinary actions from
the boards
and that seem to be a sticking point
with much of the testimony that we had
when we had a hearing for house bill
655. so um one of the things that we
want to talk about today was that what
I'd like to do is discuss that among the
committee first and then if there's
anybody that has any comments to make
um we can do that is there anybody here
who is not supposed to be here or
thinking they're in the wrong place or
nope okay good
because
um this was not in the in the electronic
calendar
and we found out that there's
some sort of glitch in the calendar that
unless you reference a bill it won't
appear in the calendar that's being
addressed by the IT department so that's
why this was this this
um meeting was originally noted a notice
for House Bill 655 and because 655 was a
was passed and sent to the Senate we can
no longer use that number
those are the things you probably didn't
know
about noticing so um
one of the I think concerns the boards
had and I'm talking to the committee I
think one of the concerns that the
boards had when we when this Clause was
put in the in the House Bill had to deal
with the fact that boards were concerned
about what their roles would be in
regarding disciplinary actions
if they're if that was repealed from
their
um statute
and I think that the intent of the
um
the bill and those statements was to
make sure that
investigations and investigation
protocol was was under the jurisdiction
of the administration the oplc portion
but adjudication would still stay as a
responsibility of the board
but because that statement was removed
from statute I think it gave the
impression to the boards that they
wouldn't have any say at all
so I think what we could do is
make sure that those those delineations
are defined in statute and that the
board does have
standing
when determining adjudication for
complaints
so I wanted to open that up to the
committee and talk about that
and if you don't want to talk about it
well go ahead the currents the current
situation is that the boards do right
and has there been a problem with that
the current situation is that the boards
um
would
you mean disciplinary actions yeah in
other words
what problem was this bill trying to fix
it we're supposed to so you really can't
have the same person doing the ins in
the you can't have the investigation
being done by the same body that's going
to do the adjudication right because you
have so that was so that that part of
the statute is what's being discussed so
that wasn't clearly defined
and that's what and the definition was
to remove that that part of the statute
from the board
however I'm not sure that in taking that
out it didn't cause an issue with
understanding of the role that the board
has an adjudication well then let's uh
let's clarify it right
I have had a couple people not on the
committee expressed to me that they're
afraid of it a little bit because they
think of it as a way station that okay
we remove
the full thing and split it and then at
some point in the future we'll just
remove it entirely
the adjudication aspect as well as the
now removing the investigation now
they're just adjudication at some point
we'll just remove the adjudication just
as easily
it's a fear you know but
maybe if we had something in there
specifying
what you were alluding to if it was
specifically in there that this is your
role
then maybe that fear would be alleviated
to some extent just one comment on that
I mean first of all you could do
something like that but I mean as I
understand that's not the intent and
realistically we can't bind to Future
legislature so I mean in the future
whatever could be done we can't
guarantee it won't but I think all we
can say is that's not what we're looking
to do at this point and there's reasons
not to do it at this point
is there somebody from an open did you
want to say something
just a response to the previous comment
no we can't bind future legislatures but
we can make the laws for the state to
abide
so you see someone from oplc that can
help get that can speak to this because
I think that
good afternoon Douglas holster how
general counsel for oplc
and Jessica calipolitis I'm the
enforcement division director at oplc
is there a specific question would you
like me to just can you go over the
current practice of how this whole
process from you know the the complaint
to the disciplinary action now and how
it would change
should we adopt the recommendations sure
and I'll do like the broad overview so
right now if a complaint were to come in
from anybody they can literally come
from anywhere including a board member
um the office would receive that
complaint and then depending on and
Jess you can correct me if I get
anything wrong but depending on the
board some of the boards like to see the
complaints up front some of the boards
uh do not but the office would go to the
board bring that complaint forward and
essentially request permission to
investigate that once we conduct an
investigation we put together an Roi
report of Investigation we bring that
back to the board the board reviewers it
they decide
if they want to see further
investigation they decide if they want
to dismiss the matter or they decide if
they want to proceed within adjudicative
proceeding so basically disciplinary
proceeding if they do decide to proceed
with discipline
then they'll send out a notice of
hearing currently oplc has prosecutors
on staff but they have to be appointed
by the board oplc provide provides
hearing officers who also need to be
appointed by the board
we go through the hearing the decisions
legal and non-legal reside with the
board you present a case
sort of like a court proceeding
um
and and then the board makes a decision
on the facts before them and then
decides discipline so some of the major
changes that we would see in
in 655 if it were to pass as it
currently is
one in investigative or rather when a
complaint were to come to the office
we would be able to review that in the
first instance decide if that claim is
with Merit or has Merit on its face so
if there's no stated violation of
Statute or rule we would so if there
wasn't one we would bring it to the
board they would make the decision
whether or not to dismiss the claim if
there is a claim with Merit on its face
we could immediately begin investigating
without going to the board for
permission
at The Point again whether or not to
proceed with an adjudicative proceeding
discipline is still in the hands of the
board in either scenario currently
though
or as 655 as proposed the board wouldn't
appoint the prosecutor to the case they
would simply be appointed by oplc and
the board wouldn't appoint the hearing
officer
they would be appointed and then also
the hearing officer would do more of the
calling balls and Strikes on the legal
matters for you know objection relevancy
kind of issues the determination uh
whether or not
there is a disciplinary whether they
should proceed with discipline or not
would still lie in the hands of the
board so the current situation I if you
look at it right now you have a
situation where the board could file a
complaint appoint the investigator to
the matter appoint the prosecutor to the
matter appoint the hearing officer to
the matter sit in and act as the jury in
the matter make legal and non-legal
determinations and decide discipline
we're trying to sort of separate some of
those roles and responsibilities give
oplc the investigative proceeding let an
oplc hearing officer make the legal
determinations again like relevancy kind
of stuff the jury or the jury well it's
a good analogy under the new Under the
new set
um so the hearing officer would act more
and more like a judge role it's not a
judge role but in a similar fashion and
the board would act more in that sort of
subject matter expert and jury role and
that would be the difference between the
process as it is now and the process
under 655 as it's written
in here so just to see if I'm
understanding correctly I'm going to use
an analogy
for the the current process and let me
know if it fits and that's uh that
basically now the board acts you know is
sort of legal you know criminal thing
would be the police doing the
investigation the prosecutor Prosecuting
acuting the case uh the judge overseeing
the trial and the jury
and the sentencing decision all right
now right is that correct all well-being
Market participants
thank you
thank you I do have a question
um
the current process of the board naming
a prosecutor and or hearing officer
I assume they have a pool of people that
they pick from to do those would that be
the same pool that ophail c would be
using it is the same group of
individuals we currently employ three
prosecutors who were assigned the cases
from the boards we have uh currently two
hearings officers as well one of them is
currently out on paternity leave but it
would be the same pool of people the the
big difference though would be being
able to call those balls and Strikes and
if the board didn't like a legal
determination they wouldn't be able to
fire the judge
another thing that was sort of expressed
to me and I don't necessarily fully
understand it but
is there some point in this process
whereby being accused you lose your
prerogatives to do certain things are
suspended or
uh and would they get better or worse or
I think that's probably more situational
you don't lose anything Simply Be by
being accused all of the complaints are
confidential and the investigations are
confidential there come could come to a
point where if the matter is decided to
move forward with discipline uh you can
sign a preliminary agreement not to
practice there are settlement options
available
there is also situations for emergencies
where uh for the you know in an
emergency situation for the public
benefit welfare health and safety the
board can decide to suspend someone's
license but they are obligated to hold a
hearing within 10 days
does that answer the question since I
don't really fully know what the
question is yes okay
so that brings up a good point
if um
are there time are there deadlines
in this in the new system that would
require certain things to be done by
certain times there are um and I think
they'd be more uniform currently you can
go to the board statutes and depending
on what
uh statute you're in you can have to
hearing notice is a good example and
probably the one we come across most
often some boards require 10 days notice
14 days notice 15 days notice one board
I think has 30 days notice this would
standardize that and say at least 15
days before a hearing the notice would
go out but we we did build in those
those timelines that already exist we
just sort of standardized them
so what are the sources of complaints I
mean how you know can you give me
examples of many types of complaints
that you receive yeah they come from all
over the place uh some of the types of
cases that would be dismissed I'm going
to use this one because executive
director Courtney loves this example
they gave me the wrong flavor jello that
would be the kind of case that we would
probably dismiss
originally depending on the board
there's sometimes
um
uh sexual physical abuse kind of
complaints drug diversion complaints
practicing without a license or
practicing with an expired license or
some of the more common complaints uh
do these do these come from the
enforcement arm or do they come I'm
trying to figure out how many of your
complaints come from enforcement
regulations like you for example the
enforcement team going out and how many
like let's say the result of an
inspection and how many are from the
public themselves
the vast majority are from the public
um and the public could be a consumer
who got a service from a licensee it
could be another licensee who
is in competition with that person it
could be a licensee that works with that
person it could be their employer it
could be the family member of someone
who had a service by a licensee it could
be a lawsuit because the courts have to
notify us regarding
um lawsuits in medical cases
um it could be
there's a number of different anyone can
file a complaint
um the vast majority do come from the
public
um and that I use that very generally
and broadly
um
there are some that certainly come
through inspections which you know we
have inspectors for borrower and
cosmetology and Aesthetics Pharmacy
electrical and mechanical
um so there are times that they find
come across something and it ends up
resulting in a complaint but the vast
majority are the public
so one of the questions I remember one
of the concerns I mean there's there's
such a variety
of boards
so I think it does make sense to have
standard deadlines and a standard form
of because this is
this it all has to do with protecting
the public right I mean that's why we
have this so
um
in the case of
I can see how in the case of a
um someone who's providing a service
like I don't know I'm gonna pick um
esthetician right then they burn
somebody's face or something like that
but then that's I can see that how does
how do elect how do complaints from the
technical boards arise because is it
that they don't follow the building
codes or they don't I'm trying to figure
out how it is that that's because there
seemed there were some concerns and the
electrical board
on how this was going to affect them
electrical complaints I think primarily
are primarily not exclusively but
primarily homeowners who hired an
electrician to do something and they
didn't finish didn't do it right there's
some other issue with with the work that
they did
so how would you oh I'm sorry go ahead I
was gonna say um I also
I spoke with Steve Rancourt who's
appeared and I think one of the big
concerns too isn't even so much with the
lplc process but with the appeal process
after the board makes a decision uh
currently
most of the boards can appeal to the
Supreme Court the electrician's board
had a different path and I that was in
SB 107 the repeal of that and and I
presented last was it last week was it
only last week but
uh house Edna I suggested I just flagged
it and said if if they're going to pull
the other things from 655 that might
also be language to appeal but I I think
a lot of their concerns in talking with
Steve and
oddly he's not here to correct me uh
that's why I brought it up yeah they
stem I think from that piece and not so
much the oplc process I'm sure he'll
correct me if I'm
misrepresenting that
thank you um so just to get a feel for
some of this I'm sure it varies widely
by profession or board
but What proportion of complaints
actually result in some disciplinary
action as opposed to end up being
dismissed
at least roughly I mean
um
we don't currently track that although
we are certainly working on
technological solutions so that we can
because I agree that is a very important
piece of information to have
um
I really wouldn't want to even even
guess and then when you talk about how
much results in discipline is that you
know goes to adjudication and discipline
is imposed does that include settlements
does that include other things or not
those are things unfortunately we just
don't track okay and that's more
thinking which got dismissed as being
more or less
baseless as opposed to something that
goes further I mean is it half to get
dismissed 90 10 just vaguely if you can
if you can't yeah that's fine I can't
what I can say is it does vary somewhat
by board
um some boards like Board of Nursing
they review every single complaint and
they decide to dismiss the ones that are
invalid on their face and then the ones
that are not we you know move through
the process at least to The Next Step
other boards don't want to see the
complaints so we at least have to
request a response and then they might
look at it some boards real estate it
says something to the effect of you
shall investigate everything so it needs
to go further so
they're depending on the board it's
going to go to a various you know
different various point in the process
okay thank you
so then the intention of this new
protocol would be that oplc would decide
they would be that they would be the
first Junction right in the decision
tree
we would review a complaint in the first
instance but nothing would get dismissed
without bringing it to the board
even in the new even in the new so if we
see a complaint and we think it's
without Merit we might make a
recommendation to the board you know
this is a wrong Jello flavor kind of
case but we aren't making that decision
or weeding anything out without
consulting the board
okay so how do we and and you want to
stay with that
you want to stay okay so
um how do we then create language
that says that because if we if we just
pull out disciplinary actions it's it's
not really
accurate as to what's being what's
happening right so you can see how this
is causing
a lot of angst because it's sort of
confusing to me too so how do we in
statute
Define
at what point is the Baton get tossed
and what point is the Baton shared
so I'm looking through the language of
655 as it currently stands I'm on page
13 of the PDF line four boards shall
conduct disciplinary and
non-disciplinarian remedial proceedings
in accordance with procedural rules
adopted by the executive director I'm
going to keep looking at the language to
see if it's more specific in here I
don't have it memorized but there is all
I mean the jail care process it's a rule
the formal rule making process so we
would have to bring everything currently
they're the PLC 200s but we would have
to bring everything through jailcar
okay so what you're saying is you're
taking that portion out of statute
and you wouldn't have the rule making
process handle that part of that was in
statue
including concerning the disciplinary
action right correct you're repealing
disciplinary action from everything and
you're putting it in the rulemaking of
oplc and oplc would be therefore setting
the rules of the new procedure for some
of it some of the things in the bill are
the presiding officer appointments or in
the language of 655 the prosecutors is
actually specifically in 655
um
let's
uh section seven of
three ten ten currently
page 13 line 31 board shall be the
triers of fact in all disciplinary and
non-disciplinary remedial proceedings
and shall determine sanctions if any so
there's that the jury role
this is why control F is nice yeah
so I think on page eight
are you looking at 655 yes the original
one
um I believe this is the one that was
amended by the house oh the amended
version okay let me look at that
um
so it's page eight
line 11.
upon receipt of an allegation of
professional misconduct the office shall
determine whether the allegation States
a viable claim if the office determines
that the allegation is not viable it
shall make a recommendation to the board
for dismissal the board shall review the
office's recommendation and dismiss the
allegation if it determines that the
allegation does not State a claim of
professional misconduct so will the
office could make a recommendation that
decision would still reside with the
board
that's if if it's going to be dismissed
correct but
six the language of 655 does not change
the fact that the board has final
disposition like final say in the final
disposition of
every matter whether it's dismissed at
some point or goes to adjudication that
is still within the board's control and
Authority
that is still their decision
okay then how do we oh I'm sorry do you
so how do we then
how do we then
um separate see I'm trying to go I'm
going back to the okay this is they're
the jury and there's this investigation
so you've done the investigation you've
determined that it doesn't meet the it
it doesn't you're you're thinking that
it should be dismissed
and then you're sending it to the board
the jury to decide whether or not that
is the case
and let's say they say it is that they
don't think that it's they think that
it's a real
complaint then what happens after that
so once we complete an investigation the
report of Investigation or Roi with a
recommendation goes to the board
and this happens now as well it goes to
the board with a recommendation let's
say we don't believe there's sufficient
facts to support adjudication in this
matter the board could certainly with
their expertise in that profession feel
differently and they could say we do
believe that this this should be
adjudicated so they don't have to accept
our recommendation they would review the
ROI and they would make a final
determination whether they agree with us
or not they can that's
up to them
and if they they think that it needs
further investigation then what have do
you do you pick it up do you do they
throw it back to you
so if we have submitted an Roi at that
point we consider the investigation
completed if they determine there's some
aspect that needs further investigation
they can certainly send it back to us
with instructions you need to do further
investigation in this area
but at that point generally a decision
would be made whether to dismiss or go
to adjudication because the
investigation is complete
management
okay so it seems to me like we're I
debating how many angels you can fit on
the edge of a PIN to some degree here
because
um uh the the real question it seems to
me is like what you
um are going to be uh
how you're going to be handling things
um and the I as I understand the idea of
the oplc is that you're going to be
providing expertise in areas in which
the the various different boards do not
have expertise so
um the oplc hypothetically doesn't know
anything about medicine
it doesn't know anything about Dentistry
it doesn't know anything about Plumbing
about electricity any of that kind of
stuff
so to the degree that you got some kind
of a complaint
what is it going to be
is it going to be that the contractor uh
defrauded customer
stole property out of the customer's
house
engaged in in various different things
which are crimes
we we don't have to get involved in any
of that because crimes are crimes
they're already illegal the only
question is is the board
a good Trier of fact and when because
they may be good doctors good dentists
good electricians good plumbers but they
may not be good lawyers
that's where you guys come in so the
question is do you have good process
that's why you provide legal counsel
that's why we have several attorneys
including yourself Mr osad so I don't
think we have to I don't think we have
to get involved in any of that the the
idea of oplc is to provide legal counsel
so that you have
procedures which are legal and you don't
have
board members who don't have any
expertise in the law may not even know
what the law is
and so they may be saying well such and
such and so and so and the board lawyer
who's part of the trial says that that's
improper
you're you're jumping to whatever it
might be where you have that expertise I
don't think we have to get involved in
any of this frankly to the degree that
you were that no PLC is going to be
providing the administrative Services
which are needed for good operation
that's what that's that that's the
structure that you are already setting
up uh and we don't I don't think we have
to get involved in specifics of any of
this frankly
management we do because in-house Bill 2
and in-house Bill 655 and in any kind of
amendment that we would recommend would
have to include somewhere in that
amendment that we are removing the
disciplinary action requirement from the
board is that right
ultimately I think that's right that's
why we're having this discussion so and
I'm glad that you that you're okay with
it because I think we're all okay with
it yes
okay
so if we can now what the other the
other item is there anybody
who wants to raise their hand yes
this is this is just about just we're
not talking about the medical review
board yet so don't that's it that's a
whole different thing
okay
go ahead
come come to the mic
thank you very much for the record John
dejoy representing the New Hampshire
Psychological Association as well as the
National Association of Social Workers
the New Hampshire chapter both
membership organizations for
psychologists and for social workers
there are three outstanding issues that
the psychologists have raised in the
Senate testimony as well as here and
there is one outstanding issue that the
social workers raised that I'd like to
bring to your attention I would like to
thank the committee though for the
extensive work you did on protecting the
confidentiality of mental health records
for clients there were multiple Pages
you added so thank you very much for
that work
the three issues are
the first is the oplc has to retain
subject matter experts
re relevant to the investigative process
what makes a subject matter expert is
not defined in the statute that's one of
the areas that we have asked in the
Senate that
specific rules be required around what
makes the subject matter expert
We Believe oplc has rules in their
existing structure to do that it was
just to put it front and center of what
makes a subject matter expert for a
psychologist versus a social worker
versus a mental health counselor so
that's important
the second piece that only applies to
the psychologists are the relative the
definitions of allegations complaints
investigations and they're used
sometimes synonymously sometimes
differently and they have the
psychologists have concerns because they
have to at least annually if not
semi-annually report to their insurers
that they are not under any kind of
Investigation or complaint process and
they want to be using the same words
Mis calipalitis reached out to me
yesterday she's asked to meet with my
clients to work those definitional
issues out and that's what we're going
to be taking that on
the third piece is in the sanctions
under the sanctions if a person is
adjudicated as committing malpractice
the board May
recoup normal investigative
costs from the person who was found who
was adjudicated to committed malpractice
we have no issue with that however the
current statute limits that
investigative recruitment to ten
thousand dollars
the amendment to 655 takes that cap out
we would like to see that cap even
understanding that most investigations
would not get to that level we'd like to
see that ten thousand dollar cap stay in
place so that folks understand the
ultimate limit that they could be
responsible for
and that's it
thank you
yes
good afternoon I'm Brad Holt I'm an
attorney at sellaway and Hollis although
I'm really coming maybe I should speak
into the mic
good afternoon I'm Brad Holt I'm an
attorney licensed in New Hampshire and
other jurisdictions
a partner at sellaway and Hollis
and a resident of the state I'm really
coming as a defense lawyer in medical
malpractice cases not representing
anyone but I think this amendment is
troubling and so I wanted to make sure
that those concerns are highlighted
and against this is sort of against our
interests this is we do represent
Physicians when they have to come before
the board and if there are more
investigations that go longer and more
complex I guess that would be good
business for us but I just don't think
it's the right practice as this bill is
amending the the prior
uh statutory scheme and so I want to lay
out a few reasons why
the amendment makes pretty broad changes
to a key element that I think
representative Schmidt maybe was
touching on the
and it actually
I just want to make sure you're only
talking about Physicians correct I am
okay but that's that is an important
point because
these are going to apply to
dozens of disparate boards and so that's
a surprise to me that the Mandate for
the oplc was to streamline the process
their the clerical duties the
administrative functions that would
probably be
similar for all boards and to get sort
of the economies of scale and
efficiencies that's that was I think an
idea to enhance throughput which
everyone agrees that the long delays are
problematic probably with every license
board or over site board
certainly from the standpoint of
Physicians if if there's a long delay in
the process a physician that was
ultimately going to be cleared has to
twist on a hook for a couple of years
that's not good
and a physician that was using unsafe
practices continues practicing for a
couple years that's not good so everyone
recognizes at least the stated problem
was we need to make this move more
quickly so the solution that several
important committees from the
legislature in the spring in the fall
rather completed had recommendations to
add resources to change some of the
rules on what a quorum would be or
participation telephonically in order to
enhance the throughput
and those resources might be included
things like stipends for Physicians that
were participating in the process and
adding their expertise to it and that
sort of thing so the stated problem is I
I for shorthand keep saying throughput
how quickly can things be adjudicated
adequately
the solution to that problem is to move
the responsibility for a significant
portion of discretionary activity
to the oplc so in the case of
that's for for Physicians but also
electricians Architects pharmacists uh
I'm not sure how taking on an additional
set of activities of initiating and
investigating cases is going to enhance
the efficiencies of those administrative
functions that the office was designed
to take on instead now the oplc becomes
the first decider on whether something
should go forward and there were
questions about if something were
recommended for dismissal would that be
the end of it no it was still within the
board's purview well that's fine but one
what's unspoken is investigations that
the board wasn't taking up
the board has medical expertise
and the oplc doesn't unless it hires it
but the board already has it with the
medical review subcommittee which
historically has and currently I think
has a radiologist
psychiatrist an OB GYN a range of of
Medical Specialties to decide here's how
we determine the standard of care here's
how we determine proper practice
moving that to the oplc doesn't enhance
that unless they're hiring experts
to stop you because the next topic that
we're going to talk about is
specifically the Board of Medicine and
the medical review board so that's a
completely different thing than what
we're talking about here so I mean that
it is it would be an exception
and that's what we're trying to figure
out and you know the whole purpose of
the
um the changes is to make sure that the
this is that the investigation you can't
possibly you must understand that if I
were to investigate and do my own
research and make my own decisions I'm
going to be biased if I'm the one who's
sitting on the hot seat right so I think
that it's important to understand that
there has to be a different group of
people doing the investigation and a
different group of people doing the
adjudication regardless of what
profession that is or do you disagree
with that no the medical review
subcommittee does the review the board
different Personnel I think there's one
ex-officio member but the board has that
Final Cut and that wouldn't change
but that's it's like a Hobson's choice
you know the story of the the guy with
horses in London or I think it was you
can choose any horse you want here's the
next one so initiation of an
investigation and proceeding with it on
an investigation Without Really any
oversight
the process is the punishment and maybe
it wasn't appropriate why didn't that
stay lodged with medical professionals
as it has been and if the throughput is
the concern we enhance that as was
recommended in a couple of committees
over the fall so the idea is
the medical review subcommittee has the
expertise to look into this and make the
recommendation the Board of Medicine
still has it lodging that in the oplc
which also has dozens of other boards
doesn't make sense to me as a citizen
thank you for coming up because uh again
I I think that we are getting into the
we're getting into the weeds in a way
that I'm not sure is moving us forward
because as I see it the oplc its
function is to provide
the kind of services and expertise that
practitioners of individual professions
may not have at all
and and and it it
and to avoid a situation in which uh the
the
oplc begins to meddle in things where it
has no expertise so we don't want the
the administrators to tell the doctors
how to practice medicine
in terms of
medicine I'm not talking about a doctor
who is very bad about record keeping
or
um or who is constantly late or who is
uh
um I I don't want to get into too many
examples you'll get the the kind of
thing
we're talking about something what has
nothing really do with misconduct
just things that need to be regulated
because of your doctor is always late
doesn't do this doesn't do that doesn't
get you a bill over charges whatever
those are all things that need to be
fixed or maybe the the practitioner has
a problem with substance use or
moral turpitude whatever these are all
things that can't be can't be permitted
or allowed to happen
but it it's not appropriate to have
perhaps the doctors uh sitting in
judgment about something where they all
know this doctor or this nurse or this
whatever right they all they all know
this person they don't want to come down
too hard on them because maybe they've
had an occasional transgression
themselves or whatever but Justice must
be done
and I don't think we should I don't
think we should prescribe all that I
think that that's the kind of thing that
that the boards should develop
themselves and not necessarily
Reinventing the wheel
we live in a very large con company
country with lots and lots and lots of
experience across the board on all this
so we should not be devising all these
things ourselves we should be cheerfully
plagiarizing if you will uh how people
in other states are doing it uh if
rather than trying to reinvent the wheel
and so I think that there I I think if
we if we say that the the board is going
to be in in charge of setting up rules
uh that we should let them do that and
if the rules are unfair or whatever that
either has to be worked out among the
practitioners
that they don't want to be too strict
about this or or whatever
um uh some things again because to the
degree that we try to Define everything
we're we're you know
I I think we're taking on a task that's
not appropriate for the legislature to
be involved in if crimes are involved
then almost certainly the either the
cops are going to get called in or the
lawyers are going to get called in and
this person is going to get sued
or maybe the doctor since we're talking
about medicine here the doctor makes a
mistake and I'll give an example
an acquaintance of mine many many years
ago
told me that she had allowed the doctors
to employ a an experimental technique on
the birth of her son
in the in the course of that delivery
they cut off the oxygen too long to this
child and he was permanently brain
damaged okay this is not the kind of
thing for him for a medical board to get
involved in this is the kind of thing
where the law has to get involved
because you talked about the ten
thousand dollar maximum fine
I think that's I think to some degree
that there's there should be either a
much higher limit or no limit at all and
to the degree that the board puts too
high of a fine on something
the the person can sue the board for
making the wrong decision I I really
don't think we should get into
specifying everything because there's no
end to it
if I can respond Madam chairman um yeah
please do that's why I ask you sir uh
the standard of care is is understood by
physicians they know some you know
medicine isn't always safe sometimes you
have to do something like chemicals that
are really bad for the body but they
kill the cancer and you've heard the
expression you know it'll cure me if it
doesn't kill me and so that question of
whether oxygen was deprived from the
baby is one that medical providers know
if this maneuver just to use your
example was appropriate to get a
umbilical cord that was wrapped
unwrapped that's not something that lay
people should be deciding that's why the
medical review subcommittee would decide
no this is one of these unfortunate
things that happen we recommend a board
that this is not negligent or this is
not Criminal
and that's why it should stay with the
people with the expertise the parallel
it's been raised in a couple of these is
that lawyers used to be you know a
professional conduct committee
and we needed to professionalize that
and it was moved to the Supreme Court
now has funded an office of
attorney discipline
if you look at that office it's
attorneys it's attorneys assessing the
conduct and they also
members of the bar in this state we know
who we know them but it's attorneys that
are deciding this was appropriate
conduct for an attorney or we're not
sure we need to look into this or no
this is this is a bad outcome or it
appears unfortunate but we as attorneys
know that so that that parallel would
suggest staying with a medical review
subcommittee and with the board for
initiating
a case so my big concern is that we're
moving the ability to initiate and
investigate
with
seems to me unfettered subpoena power
and all of the challenges and and
concerns that a defendant is going to
have in an investigation to lay people
and away from the medical people that
has historically been with the
legislature requested
I believe representative Dolan has a
question
thank you madam chair my question is
with the the oplc folks here I wonder
if we could switch back to them so I
think let me just so that's fine and I
think let me I'm so sorry in the house
bill 655 in the medical review board was
merged with the Board of Medicine and
basically looked like it was eliminated
so it's and and I think that's something
that wasn't one of the reasons why we're
having this discussion because we don't
necessarily think that's is that your
concern
both that it remains and that it's not a
Vestige oh we didn't disband it but the
process as described to you before we
only discussed when the oplc decides to
dismiss a case board could still decide
to proceed but we didn't talk about when
the oplc undertook an investigation that
medical people would have said that
that's that's part of medicine okay so
we need the medical review subcommunity
to remain
and to be part of that screening process
and that early analysis okay I
understand that's the big that's my
biggest concern okay great do we have
someone from oplc who wants to make a
comment I do want to also say I'm sorry
you can I I did let I did
um tell Mr dejoy that he could have a
few minutes to talk about this social
did you want to still talk about that or
no yes so this so representative Dolan
wanted to know if someone from oplc
wants to make a comment on the on this
situation
oh
okay representative Lucas will have a
question to you so
um thank you ma'am my uh
well I think I'm gonna try to take us
back out of the weeds and do it at the
50 000 foot level
um
my interest is going back to the
amendment
that we're talking about and with the
thought that the activities that you
guys take with respond to in response to
a complaint
uh
that eventually this is all supposed to
protect the consumer or the or our
constituents so it so my question is
with what is before us and before you
with this amendment is there anything in
that language that
is bad for or hurts the ability of
constituents of our constituents or our
citizens at Large
to have their complaints uh heard and
addressed appropriately is it does this
amendment take us in the wrong direction
by the amendment you're referring to
the 655 has passed by the house
I would say no I think if anything it's
going to speed up the process and
um
bring resolution to matters both to the
benefit of the complaining and the
licensee
but I I don't see the harm to any
constituents in doing this answer that's
my my
hope that that the matter we're taking
up takes us it causes no harm
so just to clarify
when we go to House Bill 655 it was a
huge bill right so what we decided to do
was and because it was so huge and there
were so many issues that we couldn't
really handle within the time frame that
we had we chose to take a tiny piece of
it and clarify that
so what that does is it gives oplc
um authority to issue licenses and redo
and it ties in hand in hand with their
process to go online so now we have we
have not impeded that right that's as
far as house bills the amendment what
we're talking about now is all the
leftover stuff that we didn't talk about
and it's a little messy because it's a
little bit of here and there and
everywhere
all at once so you know we can certainly
um
address it as we see fit so do you want
to talk did you have a question
representative
I promise you we will not do any harm
representative Lucas
dangerous promise but I actually have a
somewhat specific question and that is
uh
as I recall
um the cost of the investigation can be
charged the person the complaint was
brought against
at least under some circumstances is
that correct
um and what are those circumstances and
is there any limit to how much they
could end up be
that they end up being charged
um
so I believe the circumstances have to
be that it was adjudicated and that
discipline was imposed it would have to
be found that they did violate the
statutory rule
um and that discipline was imposed
um I don't know if there's a specific
limit
um within the amendment um other it has
to be reasonable I think we'd have to be
able to justify the amount we couldn't
just come up with a number
um
but is there a specific number
yeah
so I'm looking at section 310 12
proposed page 15.
in hb655 is amended by the house
um
it's the section on sanctions and if you
look down at line 26 by assessing an
administrative fines and amounts
established by the board
which shall not exceed three thousand
dollars per offense or in the case of
continuing that's the fine you're
talking about right and what page was
that again
I'm sorry what page was that again 15.
um I do remember seeing I think in the
case of unlicensed practice there was a
specific amount I don't remember
no go ahead that was so rude uh section
310 13 on page 16 beginning at line 17.
uh if you go down to line 22 after
providing notice and opportunity to be
heard and upon making an affirmative
finding of unlawful practice the board
May impose a fine not to exceed the
amount of any gain or economic benefit
that the person derived from the
violation or up to ten thousand dollars
for each offense whichever amount is
greater but that's the fine
sounds like
what you're asking specifically for
they're being charged to pay for the
investigation yeah
that was only if they're
bound to be
um in violation yeah if they're not
found in violation they don't pay them
well the next question then is what if
there's a settlement does that count
because there can people can end up
settling things even if they don't I
believe that in the con in in the
comments that Mr dejoy made the fine
there was no there was no way of
recouping
if I'm not mistaken
I don't think that is I don't think that
for some reason I'm not remembering that
in this house in the amendment to House
Bill six right I when I read through it
earlier today I think it said a
reasonable amount I don't I I could be
mistaken but I don't remember seeing a
specific amount in the amended in the
amended version correct
I mean yeah I mean the thing I'm
thinking about is you know not accusing
about PLC planning to do something
horrible but
um you know you could end up hiring a
few top experts across the country fly
them in put them up and you know pay
them you know umpteen thousand dollars a
day to do the investigation and you know
you can argue whether or not that's
reasonable but to then take somebody's
been accused of something and even if
there was some wrongdoing or maybe and
it also might be a deterrent to them
settling because you know if the
potential cost is enormous if they're
not charged if they settle
I did find the languages on page 16
section five uh line nine for any order
issued in resolution of a disciplinary
proceeding by the board
which would include settlement
agreements where the board has found
misconduct sufficient to support
disciplinary action the board may
require the licensee or certificate
holder who is the subject of such
finding to pay the office a sum not to
exceed the reasonable cost of
investigation and Prosecuting of the
proceeding I'm just pointing out the
language
I don't believe oplc made any
recommendations on this language so
everything in here was either existing
statute or at the recommendation of the
legislature
okay thank you
still have some concern on that but all
right thanks that's also why why met
doctors have malpractice insurance for
example we had a situation
roughly 10 years ago with ob gyns I
think in general malpractice doesn't pay
for fines and charges for things like
this so
okay I'm gonna stop this discussion and
I'm going to give Dr I mean John dejoy
the opportunity doctor to Joy now you've
been promoted to um to speak on your
issue and then we're going to
and that and start the two o'clock
subcommittee workshop on
okay thank you
thank you my name is Lynn Stanley I'm
the executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter I'm also a licensed
independent clinical social worker and I
live in Penacook and thank you
representative Grove for allowing us to
insert ourselves uh to very briefly
again talk about the social work compact
the language came out the end of
February which is why it wasn't
introduced uh during normal times when
bills are introduced the social work
compact would allow any licensed if
passed in New Hampshire would allow any
licensed independent clinical social
worker in New Hampshire to also practice
and see clients in the other states that
have accepted and approved the compact
I want to highlight some of the reasons
why this is important to our social
workers if you think about social
workers who are even either in private
or small group practice they're small
businesses right they have their
expenses that they need to take on or
they're working in an agency which is
often a mental health agency a service
providing agency which also has a
significant
uh Financial challenges what this would
do would reduce the expenses for that
social worker to hold their license if
they had the interstate
license your social workers right now
who are licensed in New Hampshire Maine
and Massachusetts or
New Hampshire Vermont and Massachusetts
would only have to maintain their New
Hampshire license and responsibilities
around
professional development licensing fees
Etc
uh
when considering Workforce
I think it was said the last time we
talked it's not going to expand
significantly expand our Workforce what
it will do is when social workers for
from another state move to New Hampshire
and right now South Carolina and North
Carolina are breaking their necks to get
get the compact uh enacted first if one
of those social workers was to move up
to New Hampshire they wouldn't have to
wait months in order to get licensed
here their license would be good while
they established their their home
license it also provides continuity of
care if a social worker has a client in
New Hampshire that goes on vacation goes
to college finds themselves in another
state that social worker would be able
to continue seeing their client
rather than because right now they'd be
breaking the law if they are not
licensed in whatever state their their
client is I'm happy to answer any
questions but thank you for the
opportunity to hear
so I think I made some recommendations
to Mr dejoy that it would be helpful for
us to know
the successes of the previous compacts
that we've entered
and he I believe that you're working on
that correct
that's correct I'm working with director
Courtney on that she gave me some
preliminary information this morning so
Rel there are a number of compacts where
that the state is involved in currently
one of them is the nursing compact
relative to a registered nurse
practitioners since the compact New
Hampshire has seen an increase of 25 of
availability of nurse practitioners in
the state to practice that's a
significant number I'm trying to find
similar data with director Courtney's
help regarding psychologists Physicians
and the last year passed Mental Health
Counselors
thank you okay so yes
you can have 60 seconds Mr Goulet 60
seconds for Mr Goulet
good afternoon Shane Goulet attorney
with the office of professional life
insurance certification here on behalf
of the Board of Medicine and I'm Susan
finnerty physician assistant the vice
president of the Board of Medicine so
thank you for letting us take just a
free moment we have a small proposed
amendment to HP 65 by and large the
Board of Medicine is supportive of 655.
their concerns were specifically related
to complaints and investigations and the
amendment Alters that so I have copies
if I can just pass those around briefly
okay
this is a tissue with physical
Physicians assistance
okay because there was also a concern
with telemedicine am I correct with
physical regarding physician assistance
they were not included in the television
right yeah but this is separate to that
okay separate from that okay
and I know that there was a a brief
discussion
um and some testimony earlier regarding
um uh the office's ability to vet and
utilize professional expertise of
individuals separate and distinct from
the board the board is very supportive
of you know knowing their role and
utilizing their role as the jury and
likes to stay completely separate from
the complaint process and procedure to
the best of their ability within the
confines of what's proposed with that
being said they they're hoping it has
been discussed with the office that they
want some sort of peer review in place
that utilizes the expertise within the
medical profession to vet some of these
and the board has worked well with the
office in regards to that specifically
with the enforcement department
okay and you're talking about the Board
of Medicine correct and this would be
like a peer review board
um you um that's what they would like to
see utilized um is some you know the
office under the proposal will have the
authority to control contract with
necessary experts so some form of peer
review right now uh they have physician
investigator board investigator actually
I believe two physician investigators
and then there's the mrsc at some point
they just want some you know expertise
and 655 would give the office the
authority to contract with whatever
necessary experts would you know be
appropriate to vet these okay and I okay
thank you does anybody have any
questions about this
no all right oh yes I'm so sorry
so since 655 is out of our hands now we
will have to
tackle this
amendment in a different fashion I
believe is that not the correct that's
correct so after all these this these
subcommittee workshops I'll call them
we're going to put together a
non-germaine amendment in the fall and
attach it to a bill that were retained
in committee
right so there's at this point
everything is still
for discussion
understand thank you and we do I have
not forgotten that we will add
we will discuss adding physician
assistance to the television right thank
you
yeah maybe also add nurse practitioners
yes we're going to have that yes we're
going to discuss that next week so
there's lots of little snipply bits that
we have to talk about
okay thank you so much so this ends the
discussion and we're going to move to
Senate Bill 44 which is the m ladak
board you're gonna go bye
we're going to take a three-minute
stretch okay
foreign
okay we're going to regroup
regroup
so is there someone here from the Emily
deck board that wants to talk about
house bill I mean Senate bill 44.
or
just to you know re just to get us all
on the same page sure come forward
here we go
Okay so
good afternoon everybody and thank you
for uh inviting us to speak my name is
Jackie avocoff I am uh the former chair
of the late act board uh and uh I'm an m
ladak and also a licensed clinical
social worker and and I'm Kelly ledke I
am an M ladak I am the current board
chair for the laidac board
so just to give you an overview of
sb44 as it stands before you today it
really looks at doing two things the
simple one is it changes some language
um taking out a criminal the criminal
justice requirement the criminal justice
degree as a um
as one of the degrees that automatically
gets licensed and that's because uh the
core the course of study at snhu that
that inspired that language in 2008 no
longer exists and it was it's the only
one that we know of at least locally so
uh it what it does is it moves the uh
the criminal justice degree into rule
instead of statute
uh the more important piece right now is
it looks to further expand the scope of
practice for master licensed alcohol and
drug counselors so that they are no
longer restricted from engaging in
mental health practice solely while
working with someone who is actively
working on a substance use disorder
and the logic behind this in 2010 the M
laidak scope of practice was expanded to
include the treatment of mental health
of the ability to work with someone who
understands their addiction which often
is a primary illness what what research
has told us is that addiction is a brain
disease and that it often mimics mental
illness and often causes mental illness
and needs a special kind of treatment
that integrates both substance use and
mental health what we have learned since
is that the way the language was written
it says that the M laidak who has to
have exactly the same educational
preparation as a social worker or a
mental health counselor
and in addition to that 300 hours of
co-occurring disorder and substance use
disorder education
um that person could only treat some
people with substance use disorder who
also have mental illness could also only
treat the mental illness while they are
engaged in treatment of their substance
use disorder what we've learned is
people engage in treatment of their
substance use disorder they get
connected with a recovery Community they
get connected with other uh with other
supports their substance use disorder
goes into remission it may take two or
three years they've established a really
strong relationship with their therapist
but once the substance use disorder is
not an active focus of treatment because
it's in remission that therapist can no
longer treat the mental illness
because it's only while in treatment for
the substance use disorder that what
we've learned is that interrupts a
strong relationship between a therapist
and a client it forces that person to
begin from the beginning with a brand
new person and it often leads to relapse
with the substance use disorder because
folks don't move on and start with
someone else
so that is the primary purpose
substance use disorder providers have a
focus on substance use disorder and they
treat the mental illness within the
context of that substance use disorder
whether it's active or not active
uh it's very different than a mental
health professional whose focus is
mental health and treats substance some
of them treat substance use disorder as
a as a specialty some of them have no
training whatsoever in substance use
disorder when I got my license as a
social worker
I had zero courses in the treatment of
substance use disorder that was
something that I had to learn when I got
my 300 hours of specialized training and
education I'm sorry education in
substance use and co-occurring disorders
that's the purpose what we believe is
that what this will do is support
continuity of care and expand access to
appropriate treatment providers for the
population that we Target and that is
folks with substance use disorder and
co-occurring mental health disorders
thank you want to add anything does
anyone have any questions on this yes
yes for pretty damn Schmidt
thank you madam chair
nice to see you again Jackie
thank you Kelly but I've known Jackie
for years
um so the thing is that
um
I've
lived a long life and even though I
don't happen to have substance use
addictions at least other than chocolate
um the the uh the the reality is that
many people are
they are sober for a while
then they fall off the wagon for
whatever reason uh so
it seems like it's a very delicate
balance that this current situation
imposes on you that you can only do this
unless it's Tuesday effectively you know
sometimes Sundays uh but but
does that really make any sense to have
that firewall between the two
absolutely not and in fact what it does
is it contributes to relapse because
those people who really need to continue
to be in some kind of counseling have to
start from the beginning all over with a
new person either that or so I'm the
director of a small
non-profit Outpatient Treatment Center
and one of the drawbacks of the way this
legislation is written right now is I
have to make sure that my M late acts
are also licensed as social workers or
Mental Health Counselors so we have to
make sure that we that our staff is able
to carry two licenses that's an ex
that's an expense for the organization
it's an expense for the the licensed
professionals
um I get asked the question all the time
of why don't you just
work as a mental health counselor
and uh the reality is because I'm not a
mental health counselor I'm a substance
use disorder counselor who treats the
entire person
and that includes their substance use
disorder and my carrying the M laidac
lets my colleagues know that's other
mental other health care providers know
and lets the public know that I have the
expertise and that my staff have the
expertise to work with this population
thank you
So when you say I'm looking at the
amendment that was given to us which was
shared by everybody on the subject but
on the community
I see where you take criminal justice
out and you say you were going to
address that in real making yes there's
there is a um a section in the rules
that uh that talks about other degrees
see one of the issues with uh with
substance use is we license people from
all kinds of different professions we
have aprns who become M laid acts we
have Physicians who become M laid acts
because this is who they work with and
they want to let the population know so
when we say that we have a a section in
the rules that says uh substantial uh
education that is substantially
commensurate with and that's where uh
criminal justice is uh is addressed
because there are criminal justice
degrees that deal only with criminal
justice and there are others that have a
huge piece on substance use and mental
health and if you can show us a criminal
justice degree well not me anymore but
uh that um that you have one of those
degrees that covers the clinical issues
then you will be licensed with a
criminal justice degree and actually if
I may add there is a National Standard
right now for alcohol and drug uh
counselors who have a criminal justice
degree
okay and you also so I'm looking at the
so in the amendment you have some of the
requirements for your licensing right so
you struck out but you've also increased
for Certified Recovery support workers
and you've changed it to 12 from 12 to
24 hours of approved continuing
education in the 20 so you've increased
the number of hours correct and that's
for two reasons so when those rules were
written we had no uh recovery support
workers and there was a request that we
needed these people to get uh to get
into the field as soon as possible and
to reduce the number of hours of
Education that they needed to have what
we understand now is most of our crsws
are getting more than that education
required by their centers but also there
is now a National Standard that requires
24 hours and so this gets us to not be
12 hours below the National Standard and
allows our recovery support workers to
have reciprocity with any other state
that has a similar credential
okay and you say past testing procedures
are naturally recognized credited
credentialing into entities specified by
the board
and then you've crossed out
either holding a current license issued
by the board of mental health practice
or pass the examination approved by the
board of Licensing for Alcohol and Other
Drug use professionals to demonstrate
competence too so why did you strike
that out
uh I'm sorry could you repeat which this
isn't this is I'm still talking about
the licensing right right this is this
is not for crsws is it
this is in your Amendment right okay
right
okay
right well what they did was it there's
been a national movement to uh to for M
later for Masters prepared latex to
begin working uh with co-occurring
disorders and so what they did was uh we
used to have to take two exams uh what
they did is they've now combined the
exams into one
so that's just taking out the uh the the
requirement to take an exam that no that
no longer exists
okay
so one of the things that
we as a committee
have agreed to look at is
removing hurdles from
allowing people to practice in the field
of mental health because of the
tremendous need that we have
um so this would be the only
and as amended this doesn't seem to do
that
but is there any do you have any are
there any
of course you want people that are
qualified to practice in your field
is there anything that you think
can be done to
expand
legal Workforce I think this does do
that okay the only thing because of the
because it allows you to continue okay
right it absolutely does do that it uh
it allows you to continue to work with
someone rather than having to transfer
them to another provider wait on wait
lists until another provider becomes uh
becomes available and then if they
relapse wait on wait lists to come back
to see you but this does not change the
um the reciprocity between or the the
ability to move between a mental health
license and a um and an alcohol and drug
license so there is credit given if you
have a us an licsw you get 1500 hours of
experience credit uh towards your M
laidac because what we're saying is we
at least want you to get the experience
in working with alcohol and drug drug
and co-occurring disorders similarly if
I hadn't gotten my licsw as long ago as
I had I would now have the opportunity
to count 1500 hours of my practice as an
M late act toward my licsw if I wanted
both licenses so it shortens that okay I
understand thank you does the committee
have any other questions yes
representative Fitzpatrick what's an M
latex Master licensed alcohol and drug
counselor just a little tip you you want
to be careful using acronyms because oh
I apologize because we don't all you
know Master licensed alcohol so we have
four credentials under the board of the
laidac board one is the master licensed
alcohol and drug counselor the other is
the laidac which is the licensed alcohol
and drug counselor which is a narrow
scope of practice only alcohol only
substance use disorders then there there
is What's called the LCS which is the
licensed clinical supervisor and the
crsw which is a Certified Recovery
support worker
and those are the four credentials all
of which focus on the treatment of of
substance use disorder at various levels
of expertise
are there any other questions
this isn't a question but I totally
agree agree with the logic
of what these women are testifying for
it's it certainly seems that we're
hurting ourselves by
because it's my understanding that even
though someone has recovered from a an
alcohol or drug addiction never really a
recovery there's always a struggle
always
thank you thank you
okay
yeah
so we have an amendment that was
presented to us that was sent to the
committee
so do we want to adopt that Amendment
the amendment addresses some of the
language in the bill
that was originally
um put in and it also addresses the
issue with the dupas the the the joining
of two tests Central One
um he do addresses the use of the um
let me say
it changes
um
things like
it adds mental health disorders as
opposed to
addressing substance use disorders
um
it's really mostly
I would imagine these things I think
these changes make make it more clear
no that came from
um Mr Berry who worked with them with
the board to address this and a lot of
these things are within the preview of
the board
that's their decision
so with your recommendation do you have
it I'm looking
for I sent it uh it was okay here it's
right here here is here if you want
what do you think
oh I'll be happy to move or to pass on I
don't have my paperwork here but I'm
asking about the amendment I'm asking to
pass the amendment actually the
amendment hasn't been
hasn't been sent to OLS right just
happened then we can't vote on it
we can't vote okay so this is what we're
going to do it's my fault it smells
pretty so what we'll do is before
I will go to OLS I'll have the amendment
filed and then we will send it to to the
committee
and um I'll have a subcommittee work
session to adopt the amendment
and I don't see why we would not
recommend
otph the committee based on what I've
read in the amendment and what I know if
we don't have an objection to the board
with the amendment then we can have an
agreement in in no and and we can do
that Spirit if you will and then we'll
meet a quarter of an hour before the
committee meets to have the subcommittee
to vote on the amendment all right I
think I'm not actually on the committee
the subcommittee so I can't move it
anyway but
who's on the subcommittee it's oh me
representative Dolan and representative
Fitzpatrick
there's the three of us because
representative Sanchez was not here and
around and neither is representative
Wilhelm
so
you can still have an um you have a you
have a majority of the subcommittee
absolutely
so as long as you're in business you can
still agree in principle that we'll have
the subcommittee meeting okay
you can't do anything without the
amendment
right so what I might do is I might have
I don't think you all need to come
that's up to you
um we would have we're gonna have a work
session on other things next week and I
will have the amendment and the
subcommittee can vote for it then all
right that make sense
but I don't expect any
coffee Falls
okay
so once with that I will end the
subcommittee meeting on house bill
Senate bill I mean Senate Bill 44 thank
you